good evening I'm the DI bathroom I am
the director of the social intervention
group that is still in social work it is
my great pleasure and honor to welcome
all of you to this important event to
recognize world aids day what a day is
an opportunity for people to unite in
the fight against HIV and to demonstrate
so the dirty air support for people
living with HIV and so none of those who
have died from this epidemic and finally
to celebrate the power of science in
making difference in the HIV and carlin
the team of the world aids day 2000 as
well is getting 20 getting to zero means
zero new HIV infections zero
discrimination and zero aids-related
deaths recently we made many many
advancements in the HIV prevention
science and in fact is an excellent
orderly hope that we see an end to the
HIV epidemic few objection if the
advancements that we made at HIV
research and you'll hear about them
today from from the speaker but I would
like to highlight some of these
advancements first we know that rabbits
Caleb of antiretroviral therapy and
prevention science have saved millions
of lives we also know that you and AIDS
in 2011 show that more than fifty
percent of people who need a entirety of
antiretroviral therapy are receiving
them we also know that in many countries
that are heavily affected by HIV the
rate of the new HIV infections is
decreasing as well as the number of AIDS
related death is increasing which is
great news and most importantly we know
that research showed that early
initiation of a antiretroviral therapy
reduces transmission of HIV in
ninety-six percent to the negative
and you'll hear a lot about these
findings in a few minutes from our
speakers but although we made a lot of
progress and we need to celebrate all
the advancement that we made but still
there are more than 50 if there are more
than 30 million people living with HIV
globally we also know in our country
here in the United States we have one
point 1.2 million people living with HIV
and twenty-five percent they are having
it to JV and infect it but they know
they don't know their HIV status and if
you look at what's happening in in New
York State there are hundred and
eighty-one thousand people living with
HIV and every year there are more than
5,000 new cases occurring in New York
State and there is a number of people
that have no access to our ARV they have
no access to our be because of
discrimination because of repression
because of law a lack of life insurance
on other reasons today from our speakers
you'll hear about the advancements and
the good news but also you'll hear about
the social structure barriers that
prevent people from accessing guarantee
we chosen a the appropriate person to
speak tonight a person who has been
fighting the HIV epidemic by the power
of science using science to make a
difference in policies affecting people
who are affected by HIV it is my great
pleasure and honor to introduce the
speaker dr. Judy Orbach is a friend the
distinguished speaker who has as I say
dedicated many years of her life used
the power of science to make a
difference a Judith Orbach has been
working hard to achieve the theme of
today's world aids day getting 20 dr.
Auerbach is a sociologist and is
currently an independent science and
policy consultant she served as the vice
president of research and evaluation at
the
Francisco aids foundation she was vice
president and of public policy and
program development at the foundation
for aids research and far she was also
the director of behavior and social
science and HIV prevention science
program in the office of AIDS research
at the US National Institutes of Health
she also was the assistant director of
the Social and Behavioral Sciences in
the White House in the office of science
and technology and policy she also
served a Senior Program Officer at the
Institute of Medicine dr. Auerbach
presented many many talks she she
published in many many good journals and
she influenced policies and she serves
in a number of of commissions advisory
board editorial board including the
International AIDS Society Governing
Council a global HIV prevention working
group the NIH office of AIDS research at
varying advisory council dr. Auerbach
has received a number of awards I own
includes some of them including the 2004
feminist activist award from
sociologists for women in society the
2006 research in action world from the
treatment action group in 2008 she
received career award from the
sociologist AIDS network and the recent
one in 2010 she received Thomas Kelly
leadership award from Project in forum
it is my great pleasure and honor to
introduce and to ask you to welcome dr.
or back to this presentation Thank You
nabila Thank You Baja right thank you
everybody who had anything to do with
inviting and bringing me here and making
me feel so welcome so I appreciate you
all being here I know it's kind of the
end of the day it's why we're a very
bright pink jacket and I as nabila
mentioned there has been a lot of
excitement about new developments in HIV
prevention particularly treatment as
prevention I
going to be a little skeptical so I for
warned you about that or just introduced
how social scientists have been
responding to this in particular so to
dive right in and the excitement in part
was expressed by Secretary Clinton
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton at
the International AIDS Conference bond
ki-moon from UN aids the director of UN
aids Bill Clinton who was there Elton
John who was there i mean the conference
became very much a venue in which people
were very excited and celebrating new
advances and the potential for an end to
AIDS and Secretary Clinton talked about
an aids-free generation so the feeling
was that we're now poised to use tools
in our toolbox and new inventions and
tools to bring about an end to this
epidemic and the optimism came from the
results of a few trials a few studies of
new prevention technologies as they're
referred to and in particular using
antiretroviral treatment for HIV
prevention purposes I'll say a little
bit more about that one trial in
particular a clinical trial that's known
as HPT and 052 which is the HIV
prevention trials Network 052 sealed the
deal on this whole approach and I think
really made it possible for people to be
so optimistic about treatment as
prevention so I'll say a little bit
about that study and it sort of became
heretical for anybody to cast any doubt
about the aids-free generation or an end
to AIDS but many social scientists and
others i think thought it was at least
important to interrogate how possible
this really is and what what lies behind
the claim and what does not so what's
all this really about I'm going to try
this manually one of the concerns are
part of why some of us are a little less
than entirely enthusiastic is that
treatment as prevention very quickly
seem to have become treatment is
prevention sort of squelches out all
other prevention and a lot of people
like myself and nabila
others have been engaged in prevention
science and prevention program
implementation and policymaking and
activism feel like and believe that
prevention is prevention so to have
treatment as prevention become treatment
is prevention and suggest that it really
now is the sort of Savior strategy for
HIV prevention feels and probably is
somewhat problematic and of course we
live in an era of constrained resources
and so part of the push towards
identifying the Holy Grail or the single
magic bullet as we like to say in this
case treatment as prevention is because
we all do believe we should be more
efficiently and effectively targeting
what limited resources we have on the
most effective strategies for HIV
prevention but because it increasingly
feels like a zero-sum game and budgeting
around prevention people are a little
bit nervous about the suggestion that
all we have to do is treat everybody
with these antiretrovirals and we'll
both improve the health and well-being
of people living with HIV and also make
it possible to not transmit or acquire
HIV infection by taking the drugs so to
really begin to unpack this it's
important to start with the evidence and
I think some of you are probably more
familiar with this evidence-based than
our others most of the evidence behind
treatment as prevention comes from
randomized clinical trials at those that
relate to using antiretrovirals to
prevent transmission so treating
positive people who are eligible and
ready for treatment to reduce the amount
of virus circulating in their system
reducing the viral load or viral burden
which has been shown or viral
suppression as it's also called which
has been shown and hypothesized to
reduce the likelihood of transmission
less virus in your system less likely
you are to transmit it and that's what
HPT no.52 was really all about and it
showed in the study that i'll say a
little bit more about as we go along a
ninety-six percent reduction in
transmission risk for among sterile
discordant couples that is one person
who's positive one person who's negative
the positive person taking the drugs not
transmitting to the negative person in
mostly African context but a few others
as well so that's why everybody got so
it
ninety-six percent Risk Reduction that's
close to what we've said about condom
male condom effects efficacy of about
ninety to ninety eight percent there
also were clinical trials and have been
and continue to be using antiretroviral
treatment to prevent acquisition so
actually the negative the HIV negative
person taking these drugs in order to be
sort of prepared that should they come
in contact with HIV virus it won't take
up and these I've just listed the names
of some of the trials that have shown
efficacy that is reducing HIV infection
risk by anywhere from 42 to seventy
percent or seventy-three percent
depending on this study also very much
depending on whether people actually
took the drugs all the time as
prescribed if people adhere taking the
drugs as prescribed religiously you can
see infection rates drop as much as
ninety percent the subsequent data are
showing us the fem prep study listed
here is one that was among women
specifically hence the name FEM in case
you were wondering and that was a very
equivocal study that did not show
protective effective prep pre-exposure
prophylaxis using antiretrovirals as a
negative person to not acquire infection
and the hypothesis is it's because women
had very low rates of adherence that is
they didn't take the drugs as they were
supposed to that's a whole other story
so we have these randomized clinical
trial data particularly HP TN 05 to
there have also been observational
studies of what's referred to as
community viral load so that's looking
at the amount of virus in a community
across the board let's say a city like
San Francisco or British or Vancouver in
British Columbia and that's possible for
public health departments who have blood
samples for example and saying well as
the population has had more
antiretroviral circulating among it more
people are treated do we see infection
rates decline and there are data
supporting that for these two cities and
others are applying approach now now
what's really important to note I got to
me gizmos up here right from the start
and thinking about that evidence the
randomized control trial evidence which
is particularly where the treatment as
prevention
approach is based and for specifically
HP TN 05 to as a focus those studies are
what we call efficacy trials they can
show that in very rarefied perfect
research conditions when controlling for
all kinds of noise that exists in real
people's lives with you know very very
intensive clinical and counseling
expertise and interaction going on so
under ideal circumstances we can assess
whether some kind of intervention or
technology works typically at the
individual level meaning a person but
what happens when you put that kind of
technology or intervention out in the
real world that's when we're really
interested in what we're really
interested in is what happens do we see
the same level of effect we have
effectiveness so there's a difference
between efficacy and effectiveness
effectiveness is really about the impact
of these interventions or technologies
in the real world under resource
constraints with all the noise that goes
on in everybody's lives and so on
effectiveness also relates to
generalizability so if you do a study or
you assess the efficacy of an
intervention or a product in this case
antiretrovirals in one community or one
subpopulation might you expect the same
effect in another community population
so that we'd argue we should scale it up
all over the place so that difference
between efficacy and effectiveness is
one that social scientists raise all the
time and say that you know what really
matters in life is effectiveness and
these clinical trials don't exactly show
that generalizability is the other so
speaking of that one way to think about
it and when we start to say can we
translate the efficacy data into
effectiveness is to say well HPT and it
used to ask the question for whom is
treatment as prevention really an
appropriate strategy and HP TN was done
as I mentioned a number of African
countries also Thailand and the US and
Brazil I believe most of the countries
have what are called generalized
epidemics where there's HIV about among
two percent of the total population of
the country or more there are a lot of
places in the world the u.s. included
that have concentrated epidemic
so we have HIV infection rates across
the whole population of much less than
1% but in certain population groups like
gay men we have a much higher percentage
certainly well beyond two percent so
that's true in a number of other places
so david holt grave and his colleagues
looked at the question of for whom would
test be appropriate in the united states
and this would be true for other
developed countries or countries that
have not just developed countries that
have concentrated epidemics where
there's high rates of infection among
typically gay men and other men who have
sex with men sex workers commercial or
otherwise and drug users particularly
injecting drug users which is usually
where you find infection concentrated so
they come up with they came up with six
different kinds of population groups in
the US for whom you'd want to ask the
question and as you can see on this
listing what I've highlighted is the one
they would argue and I would agree is
really the most relevant population for
treatment as prevention that is HIV
positive people who know their HIV
positive as nabila mentioned about
twenty to twenty-five percent of
Americans who are HIV positive don't
even know it they've not been tested or
they've not received the results of
their test so people who know they're
infected otherwise they would never be
accessing treatment of course and who
are engaging in some kind of risk
behavior behavior that can result in the
transmission of HIV infection if they're
not having risky sex if they're not
injecting or sharing drug equipment
there's no risk for HIV infection so so
it's that combination that would be
really relevant for treatment as
prevention and that is estimated to be
about sixteen percent of the eighty
percent who know their HIV positive who
transmitted all together over fifty
percent of infections so their argument
was that's really who'd be relevant for
treatment as prevention in places with
concentrated epidemics like the US but
as i was already hinting the HP TN 05 to
study population was very different that
was heterosexual couples Cyril discord
meeting one positive one negative but in
long term couple relationships
ninety-four percent of whom were married
very low rates of any reported
unprotected sex meaning not using
dems over ninety percent reporting
consistent condom use that's always a
sketchy one because people it's
self-report and people are dubious about
self-report but at least pretty fairly
high rates of condom use and very low
rates of reported anal intercourse which
we know is a higher risk transmission
activity so the point is that that
sample may not really characterize a lot
of other populations for whom treatment
as prevention would be thought of and it
may not the findings from that study may
not apply to riskier sexual practices
like anal intercourse that are relevant
for certain populations like gay men in
particular but also heterosexuals and
people for whom as I said treatment as
prevention might be more relevant most
relevant so another way besides looking
at the clinical trials and asking about
efficacy effectiveness and
generalizability another way that social
scientists have assessed the evidence
around treatment as prevention or
treatment is prevention is to say well
what about places where treatment has
been widespread for some time
antiretroviral therapy in particular has
been widespread and taken up and used by
people for a long time do we see
declining rates of HIV infection are
they not transmitting and people not
acquiring and so if we look at gay
populations in particular a panel who
looked across a number of developed
countries in North America Australia
Western Europe and the UK concluded that
in fact HIV epidemics among gay men and
other men I'm sorry I always say gay men
instead of just the MSM because I have a
problem with that man I think it's sort
of silences it makes invisible game and
that's for you the mysterium and they
would hermeneutics over there and you're
welcome but the point is that HIV
epidemics among gay another men who have
sex with men are generally stable or
increasing in the same time frame as
we've seen a lot of takeup of
antiretrovirals within those communities
and you can see that for the United
States where HIV infection rates among
gay men have not declined in the United
Kingdom that's the red line here Fran
the blue turquoise bars or Canada or
Australia so why is that well there are
a number of reasons that we may not be
seeing declining incidence among gay men
even while there's a lot of treatment
use among their gay male partners who
are hiv-positive and these are things
that really have to be considered
whether it's the higher baseline risk of
anal sex multiplied over time so a whole
lot more anal intercourse the fact that
there are probably a lot of untested HIV
positives within the gay community as
well as other communities there are a
number of people who even on treatment
on these very active highly active and
effective antiretrovirals are not
achieving viral suppression the drugs
just aren't working for them in the same
way as we'd like so there is a certain
amount of virus that is still in the
body and circulating we don't hear as
much about those as i mentioned
adherence problems to that people may be
on the drugs but not taking them as
fully as prescribed they might interrupt
their treatment go on treatment holidays
and things like that and then there are
a bunch of a number of biological or
physiological issues as well relating to
prevalent sts other sexually transmitted
infections which heighten the
possibility of transmitting and
inquiring HIV biologically and partner
concurrency having multiple concurrent
that means at the same time sexual
partners which is very common in a lot
of gay communities so there are a number
of biological physiological behavioral
and social structural issues that may
have something to do with why even in
the face of a lot of treatment we're not
seeing declining infection rates among
gay men and some of this is unpacked in
a meta review a medicine thesis of 53
studies of gay men looking at men know
who are HIV positive whether or not in
the context of treatment they've
increased or reduced their so-called
risk behavior that is unprotected sex
with partners of either the same or
different HIV status and what they found
in this meta-analysis is that they're
still high levels of unprotected anal
intercourse among gay and other
MSM who know that they're HIV positive
much of that kind of sex occurs with
partners who are HIV negative or of
unknown HIV status so it could be that
there's treatment optimism there that
unprotected sex is much higher among
positive gay men than among negative MSM
and and all these longitudinal studies
are showing increases in unprotected
anal intercourse which suggests that
there may be what people call risk
compensation or optimism about
antiretroviral therapy reducing the
possibility of transmitting that that
optimism about that has led people to
abandon condom use and that's a concern
so it's really a question about whether
making people aware of the benefits of a
RT of antiretroviral treatment may have
the effect of in fact increasing
transmission risk behavior so just to
sum up this part the evidence around
treatment as prevention although it's
very promising and it appears to have
great potential to reduce HIV
transmission the population level
effectiveness of the strategy has not
yet been established or demonstrated and
that effectiveness is mitigated or its
least affected by biological behavioral
and social structural factors that can
include things like not detecting as
much as we'd like acute HIV infection
early infection in which the virus is
much the viral load is much higher in a
person and you're more likely to
transmit we're still having difficulties
detecting that increased rates of
unprotected unprotected sex among
hiv-positive persons as I mentioned with
gay men continued high prevalence of HIV
in communities so the more people live
longer with HIV infection the more pool
of HIV infection fected transmitter so
to speak there is in any community and
there are a lot of people who are not
accessing or adhering to antiretroviral
therapy and related care
and this whole question they're getting
back to going from the evidence for
efficacy to effectiveness i think is
borne out that are the challenges of it
and the difference between efficacy and
effectiveness is borne out when we look
at what is now a very famous treatment
cascade which shows that starting with
people who know their HIV infection at
every step along the trajectory towards
getting on and getting linked to care
getting on antiretroviral therapy taking
the drugs is prescribed and then seeing
reduced viral load or viral suppression
that supposedly would help reduce
transmission we see a terrific amount of
drop-off so that in the United States of
that 1.1 million Americans living with
HIV only about twenty-five percent or
actually virally suppressed so at a
population level would we we may not be
seeing this treatment as prevention in
the same way and so why is this the case
well a social scientists point out it's
because effectiveness is a contingent
outcome it's very much dependent on a
lot of things that go well beyond a drug
and its power to act in a cell in a
laboratory or in a single single
person's body it's dependent on the
collective activity of diverse actors
which means not just people but also
technologies and how one interacts with
them the meanings you give to taking a
pill or using a condom how you negotiate
in your relationships around them and
effectiveness is also contingent on
legal decisions that affect the desire
the ability to the access to any
prevention strategy and of course a
whole set of norms values and discourses
that animate our behavior and our
practices another way to think about
this in un aids speak is that
effectiveness very much depends on
critical what they call critical
enablers so if we look at the
acceptability and it's sustained take-up
of technologies like antiretroviral
therapy medical male circumcision which
is also part of the ending AIDS
package we see that these are very much
dependent of course on the technologies
but also on things like political
commitment cultural understandings and
values loss policies and practices
community mobilization and stigma
reduction which are all the kinds of
things that we think of as social and
structural factors or environmental
factors social drivers social
determinants the things that make people
more or less vulnerable to HIV infection
and also make it more or less possible
and desirable to engage in HIV
prevention so attention to these social
factors in HIV epidemics and the
responses to them was the other thing
that was predominant at AIDS 20 set 12
besides treatment as prevention and it
was mainly characterized nowadays at it
has been as so the social determinants
of health so we're looking at upstream
factors these social and environmental
factors that cause or influence health
and illness outcomes and this is
something that's been evolving in public
health generally not just HIV as as you
probably know it's also connected to
growing interest in the connections
between Health and Human Rights so these
upstream social factors have variously
been called social drivers which was
popular in the age twenty thirty one
project in which I was involved and so
we were kind of forced into the social
drivers terminology here you can see un
aids had its definition and I and my
co-authors had ours but they they're
very similar in saying that we're
looking at social and structural factors
that turns out or not that easy to
measure and to identify to
operationalize but they're very things
that are reflective of how we arrange
ourselves socially and act with each
other socially and they operate around
and in concert with individual behaviors
as well as technologies and structures
and systems so that was social drivers
that lasted for a few years and now
everybody's onto social determinants but
again we're pretty much talking about
the same thing the World Health
Organization has really taken off in
advancing a social determinants of
health agenda as has the US Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention in the
context of HIV and you can see in the
World Health organized
definition that they actually emphasize
inequality and power and resources is a
feature of how social factors play out
in health and illness such that we see
differential outcomes and health and
illness or health disparities as we like
to say locally and when you think about
okay so how do we start conceptualizing
and operationalizing and mapping out how
these social factors poverty well gender
inequalities political economy law
policy how do we how do we make these
sort of concrete you can see the World
Health Organization's schema their frame
or their conceptual framework looking at
how social and political context on the
far side over here translate through
some social factors that are slightly
more easy to operationalize through all
out to the actual health outcome so
there's structural determinants very
high order intermediary determinist to
get at more individual health behaviors
and biological factors and then the how
they interact to eventually affect
health outcomes but when we really think
about how these social structural
factors operate we have to contend with
some things that make it quite difficult
to study them scientifically
particularly when we start getting to
interventions but even on a basic level
because social factors drivers
determinants are not unilateral
variables they're not two things that
you can say X causes Y you know this
very linear direct causal one-to-one
linkage they're interactive phenomenon
they reflect very complex social
processes they're complex their fluid
they're nonlinear and they're contextual
they interact dynamically with
biological psychological behavioral and
other fact social factors and we have to
characterize them situationally and
contextually gender does not look the
same in one context as it does in
another wealth poverty in the
distribution of material resources may
be different in one situation and
another and just to make that point you
often hear in the aids discourse that Oh
gender inequality causes
aids or discrimination against women
causes AIDS amongst women and it's
really not that simple in fact gender in
my book includes all social arrangements
that have to do with sex and so I think
genders are relevant construct for
understanding what's happened with gay
men in this epidemic but people tend to
think gender equate with women so I'll
just talk about that for a moment but if
you look at the data there are places in
southern Africa which is where people
generally make this argument where in
fact young women have HIV infection
rates anywhere from three to eight times
higher than young men there same age
group and many people attribute that to
the kinds of gender-based inequalities
that young women face in those settings
that lead them to have to depend on men
typically older men for material goods
and support even love but particularly
for material goods to pay for school
fees or uniforms or to buy the latest
new shoes or whatever it might be so the
economic inequality by sex or gender is
is supposedly one part of the equation
and general norms and cultural norms
around women and men very high rates of
gender-based violence in southern Africa
and South Africa in particular so gender
equality might actually contribute to
those differential infection rates
between young women and young men but if
you look at another setting in the near
eastern North Africa are places that
have very fundamentalist religious
cultures you can see a terrific amount
of gender inequality and very abject
oppression of women but see no
significant HIV infection rates at all
much less greater than than males so
gender inequality in and of itself can't
be said to cause AIDS you have to really
unpack how it operates and in what ways
same with poverty and wealth there are a
lot of very poor people who have very
high rates of HIV infection and you can
understand as Social Work people why
that would be the case but it turns out
in southern Africa the wealthiest
countries have the highest HR
the infection rates like Botswana so
again it's not just poverty or wealth
it's how that is manifest in human
relationships to confer through
behavioral and other social factors and
biological to confer differential poner
ability to HIV infections so you're
getting a sense of the complexity of
this if you didn't already know it and
just to really underscore it this is a
graphic produced by Charlotte wats
looking at how we can trace the pathways
of association between inter partner
violence and women's risk of HIV
infection and she does start with social
level factors at the top and works
through sexual or physical
characteristics or factors and some
behavioral and social ones through
biologic and behavior intermediary
effects down to the increased likelihood
of HIV transmission actually occurring
to women and you can see the complexity
because there's arrows going all over
the place these things interact with
each other and so it does become very
difficult to chart the pathways you know
fully and then think about how you going
to translate that into some sort of
intervention or program design what I
also wanted to point out how her
starting point is not where some people
would start there's even larger order
macro social factors that influence
these very things up here that influence
poverty and economic stresses are the
social constructions of masculinity and
those are things like history culture
political economy so the question is how
far up the food chain to go where to
enter the causal change Shane if we
really want to get a grip on the HIV
epidemic and we really want to bring an
end to it as social scientists or people
who look at social factors the further
out we go the more elusive and and
confusing things can get or problematic
for people and I there are two books
that came out in the last year or so
that sort of do this they actually go
back to the day start with the question
how did AIDS emerge in the places it did
in Africa and say trace back the
epidemics to you know obviously a path
in that jumped species but then how did
it take off in human populations they
trace it back to colonialism as a social
historical cultural process that
produced or inflicted a certain kind of
reorganization of work so a lot of labor
migration people forced to go and work
in camps that then resulted in the
creation of sex work communities around
to service the male laborers that
creates a situation right for a lot of
transmission of sexually transmitted
infections including but not limited to
HIV infection so I guess you could ask
you know should we as aids aids
researchers be looking at colonialism as
a sort of social determinants of health
and this really is an issue and it's
been an issue in the social science
literature about social determinants of
health it's been a bit of a debate I
have a long quote here which I won't
read but it comes from two of the folks
who really initiated a lot of the
attention to social determinants of
health back in 1995 who believe that we
really do have to look at these
fundamental or kind of what I've been
calling macro social causes the really
high order social determinants and
factors that influence epidemics because
if we don't if we deal with the
intermediate ones we're going to put a
bandaid on something for the short term
but if you haven't rearranged the
political economy or social relations
between men and women those are going to
resurface again and just disadvantage
the very same people all over again so
people have different positions about
this and in the the scientific world we
tend to keep reverting to the
intermediary for a number of reasons one
is because you know this kind of
argument about having to deal with
things like colonialism or history or
you know gender inequalities and in a
cultural way religion these things are
very scary they sound too political they
sound too radical they sound too far
afield from HIV if you're an HIV
research funder and they don't really
fit neatly into intervention science
paradigms that
come to predominate the research
Enterprise so as a result as I mentioned
you know in the research arena the
biomedical and clinically kind of
dominated research agenda in which we
all work most attempts to address the
social intervention studies and
intervention science do end up focusing
on more intermediary determinants which
are actually much more easy to
operationalize to measure and to
evaluate and I just wanted to show you
this framework that is an attempt to try
to bring the biomedical behavioral and
high-level social structural factors
together this is developed by the
research to prevention project at Johns
Hopkins University that's doing work
internationally and so they actually
have a nice schema here that says we
have these aspects biomedical behavioral
and social and structural we can
identify what the drivers or
determinants are at each of those and
what kinds of interventions are relevant
that address those factors to get at the
outcomes we would measure that have to
do with reducing HIV transmission so
they've got poverty there and they've
got risk environments as kind of social
level factors but when it comes to
translating that into an intervention
the high level macro social things
disappear because they're very hard to
operationalize you have to make things
concrete so their intervention for
Tanzania ends up this is a combination
package which is what everybody's trying
to do now have biomedical or biological
behavioral and social approaches or
strategies in a comprehensive
combination kind of prevention approach
so they've got a cash transfer project
which is about poverty or economic
inequities it's about gender and neck
ways because it's about giving
vulnerable women some kind of material
cash resource in which she can create a
business or become less dependent on men
for income so that she doesn't have to
engage and sexually doesn't want to or
unprotected sex for example they've got
a testing and counseling intervention
which could be about stigma people not
wanting to know their HIV infection so
they don't get tested and medical male
circumcision which could be about
culture that's the biologic intervention
or by a lot
gical technological so that the macro
social pieces kind of disappear and
rather the intervention components are
specific manifestations of them that can
be more easily operationalized for
intervention research purposes so as
researchers again operating in this
dominant biomedical and clinical science
paradigm in in AIDS research it really
does remain an unsolved challenge about
how best to incorporate a social
determinants lens particularly when you
get to the intervention the applied end
of things and I wanted to finish
basically with a nod to implementation
science which is where some people think
we bring together the biotech biological
new prevention technologies with the
social and structural how we get from
efficacy to effectiveness and this has
become the sort of tour term du jour for
making that happen basically and it's
become a huge priority at the NIH and
PEPFAR the President's Emergency Plan
for AIDS research which the AIDS relief
excuse me which is the US government's
global aids program you've probably
heard about huge program that's had a
tremendous impact and at the Gates
Foundation which is a huge funder of
AIDS research so they've all gotten into
this nomenclature of implementation
science as a way to get to effectiveness
by focusing on the operations of health
systems which in which supposedly
efficacious HIV prevention and care
interventions are delivered and you can
see from this definition that that's the
emphasis improving quality and
effectiveness of health services in care
so while implementation science which
you can also see from this definition
includes or has its origins and things
like business and economics and
sociology which are social science and
some of the social sciences behavioral
economics and so on it's really not a
substitute for social science which is
why I mentioning it here it's as if the
field has decided oh good we have
something new we can talk about that's
really about the operations of health
systems and delivery systems and we
like get over that stuff about macro
social determinants that are so
problematic for us to deal with what we
really are interested in is just getting
these technologies out to people and
maximizing their opportunities to take
them up because of course they will
right if they're available so you know
it's a very important part of the the
package it's really important that we
have a smooth operating health systems
but it's not a way to avoid dealing with
the social factors and determinants that
create this inequitable social
relationships that produce the kind of
systems that we're now trying to make
have higher quality and more efficacy so
just to conclude you know how to sort of
bring this together and it not very nice
and neat way because it's a not nice new
subject increasingly people are coming
to recognize that the distinction
between the biomedical and the social
behavioral is not particularly useful
but it's so resilient people keep
slipping back into it because it defines
our scientific paradigms the ones in
which each of us works we get take
courses we get degrees we write papers
we get funding so it's very hard to
break out of it there are a lot of
categorical funding streams that keep
reinforcing the distinction and there
are true believers who think like a lot
of clinical and science people do who
think you just give people pills and
that's you know that's really going to
do the trick so it's but pills have to
be taken by people people live in social
contexts that make that a desirable or
undesirable thing to do and so on so
that distinction is not particularly
meaningful even though it's resilient we
obviously need a lot of social science
around treatment as prevention and other
new prevention technologies we didn't
really talk about those for time like
medical male circumcision is the big one
to understand who what when where why
and how these are going to be attractive
or not treatment is prevention and other
new prevention technologies and social
and structural approach that approaches
should be part of a combination approach
which can mean a scientific scientific
intervention version like the one I just
showed you from Hopkins that's
constructed as a research project and
carried out is very large kind of
having biological technology and
behavioral strategy and a social
structural intervention and testing in a
very controlled way the efficacy of not
the effectiveness of that but it can
also mean you have some science over
here but you also have program and you
have policy actions that occur informed
by the science but are not waiting for
scientific results necessarily so we
need a much more comprehensive approach
which some people have referred to as
social Public Health and of course
social and structural change is
concomitant with bio technological
change you're not going to have one
without the other so we need systems to
deliver technologies effectively and
equitably we need demand by persons to
use the technologies you may build it
but they may not come if they're not
interested in and we need supportive
environments to make both of those
things possible and that includes the
financial end of things a structural
access to HIV prevention and care
services but also payment for them and
it includes human rights stigma
elimination and decriminalization and we
as you probably know there's a lot of
criminalization of HIV itself and
transmission through sexual behavior so
we need the kind of supportive
environments that are going to enable a
comprehensive approach and finally as i
mentioned i think implementation science
is not really the missing link between
efficacy and effectiveness or biomedical
and social structural it's an important
part but it's not a substitute for the
kind of social research we really need
and with that I'll just acknowledge
people who let me some of their slides
and thank you for your attention and
we'll be happy to take questions thank
you
thank you for the fabulous lecture
actually didn't need you it almost
worked and had Auditor I mean I'm
thinking through all the ethical
implications of treatments for lunch I I
don't like that title that drives me
just chillin on that night horrible but
it it provides not treatment for
treatment and treatment before treatment
and prevention proper social science
play a role in resolving some of ethical
considerations in pushing treatment as
prevention in countries like South
Africa
lower-income countries you know although
the push is going to be to put everybody
with c4 house you know senator basically
that knows when these countries having
achieved getting you know
200 adhering to treat our countrymen
viral loads of crushing the huge viral
discussion issue so I was going to ask
you to find what you thought were the
ethical problems but I think you've just
given us one so it's you're questioning
I don't know if it was laughing up to
here but really gets at some of the
questions about will treatment as
prevention or treatment is prevention
become mandatory or coercive so that we
are seeing a movement towards treating
HIV positive people from the beginning
at the time that you know that they're
infected and so as you were looting I
are you all familiar with HIV and cd4
levels and things like that you know so
whether you are eligible for
antiretroviral treatments has been
historically dependent on the measure of
your t-cells and now to a great extent
viral how much viruses circulating in
the system and the theory was let's not
put people or let's not have people take
drugs even that languages it's always
interesting to me let's put people on
drew people should not necessarily take
drugs these strong drugs too early
because you can develop resistance over
time and you don't want to eliminate
possibilities of drugs eventually
helping folks so but because of this new
data about not only can early treatment
improve health outcomes which there is
good data foreign in many cases for the
positive person themselves but also help
not transmitted infection there is kind
of an imperative for people to get on
treatment antiretroviral treatment
earlier than before so I think you're
raising a very significant ethical
concern which has to do with how
coercive this is now going to be for
just just talking about treatment as
prevention for positive persons
preventing transmission there's a whole
other similar discussion going on around
pre-exposure prophylaxis should all you
know gay men who have a lot of sex who
are HIV uninfected start taking these
drugs to prevent acquisition could be a
similar question and it has been raised
so to get to your question behind the
question about what can social
scientists do to point out some of these
things well the most important thing is
to point them out by doing and
developing evidence
they may or may not be as deep a concern
as you've articulated them we may think
that their greater concern than they
actually are two people but doing
qualitative research focus group
research whatever is the relevant
methodology for ascertaining what people
know how they know it and what they
think about it is really important part
of this package because a lot of this
approach that comes without that it's
just again an assumption that a lot of
clinical doctors and scientists have
that you know if you build it they will
come because we know how great it is and
why wouldn't you take a pill if you know
it could prevent transmission so we need
to be able to provide some of the more
nuanced responses that people have to
drugs it's not just the drug it's how
people interact with them
I think it's also important since nobody
jumpin up with a hand and another
ethical consideration I think you either
said or alluded to has to do with the
inequitable disk potentially inequitable
distribution of these strategies so do
all people have equal access to
treatment for treatments purposes or for
prevention purposes or not and if not we
have to as social scientists explain who
and why yeah I don't think it's the
focus of your presentation that we
talked about circumcision as something
that
now being focused on
I don't know much about okay I'm glad
you mention that because we talk about
these things in the field I'm not sure
as well known as other song I'm glad to
other people I'm glad you asked so there
and it's another interesting case of yet
another talk I have given and would love
to have that has to do with what
evidence counts in HIV prevention and we
had a number of observations over time
that in countries with low with high
rates of male circumcision that were
done typically for cultural reasons
religious or tribal or whatever there
were lower rates of HIV infection than
in other parts of the world so at an
observational level there were people
pretty early on in the epidemics Angie
it looks like circumcision is protective
for HIV acquisition at least acquiring
infection but that wasn't good enough
and so over time you know there was all
this pressure to have randomized control
trial data to prove whether circumcision
reduces trans acquisition or
transmission risk and so that occurred
and in the early mid 2000s 2005 I think
was the first study there were three
sequential randomized clinical trials in
again African context Uganda South
Africa I forgotten the third that
demonstrated that male circumcision when
conducted with adult men voluntarily in
a clinical medical setting by trained
physicians could reduce HIV acquisition
among those men so men acquiring from
women predominately were not men who had
sex with matter at least didn't say that
they did it could reduce their risk of
acquisition by over fifty percent fifty
to sixty percent so that got the field
very excited particularly after three
studies pretty much showed the same
result and now that's a big pillar of
the combination prevention strategy or
the end to AIDS or you know strategies
that people talk about because that's an
interesting one because gay men around
the world said you've got to be kidding
you know this is not something that we
really want to advocate for you know
it's the intact penis guys or the penis
integrity there are groups of people who
are very adamant about non
in their American Academy Pediatrics was
not advocating for circumcision of
infants at the time and so it's very
controversial but it turned out in a lot
of African context Swaziland and
elsewhere men were lining up as soon as
it was offered men for whom this was not
a cultural norm it was not a traditional
or typical behavior but they had heard
and they had internalized that this
procedure might reduce their risk of
acquiring HIV infection so they were
quite happy to have the procedure done
so it's a very interesting case the
scallop is fascinating because it's
another one where in the clinical trial
context the procedure was done in these
very medical medically sterile
conditions with highly trained people
and there was some concern that folks
that setup circumcision shacks along the
road and just you know hack moth hack
off the foreskin with the handy tool
that's not happening so much but there's
been an interest in looking at simpler
ways of doing Mel circumcisions and
training people who are not physicians
to do the procedure and this school so
it's a very long complicated story but
that's a very important pillar now of
HIV prevention and scale up the
attraction has been huge for men but the
implementation has been more difficult
in some places than thought for mostly
bureaucratic reasons funding another but
it's another one that's still
controversial because back to your point
there are a lot of people who thought
okay first of all this was male adults
how does that translate to infant
circumcision so the guys people who
still don't like Britta's and the other
cultural practices of circumcised and
infants said you know this how do we
know that these data really apply to
infant circumcision and then there was a
sensor are we going to now feel like all
men have to be circumcised
by then there's a second part of the way
he's the social structure issues how
much they look at the social structure
gender inequalities in old fight not
much across the board yeah I'm not sure
there were any acknowledged injecting
drug users they were in Thailand they
were in Brazil they were there was you
know two couples I think in the u.s. in
the sample so over I think it is over
900 of the seventeen hundred or so
couples in the study came from African
Southern African context in Kenya but my
recollection I don't know what the insta
details of that study but it was not
really set up to look much at the social
or behavior certainly behavioral but not
so much the social structural aspects
that we might find relevant and I don't
think there were many of any injectors
and we're looking at couples so I'm not
sure how they would have worked that in
to the equation it's what are the most
significant policy issues that you're
experiencing with
the use of implementation
and how that impacts
Wow first my head was going what are the
big policy issues then you threw in the
implementation science and well there's
policy with a big P and then there's
kind of science policy so I think I was
reacting to a great extent of the
science policy part of it whereas where
in the scientific community lands on
some new construct and decides this is
the end-all and that's where I think the
implementation science approach has the
possibilities but it's also highly
problematic particularly from the view
of a social scientist who thinks it's
supplanting any attention to two real
social science it's very mechanical it's
about the operations of systems so you
know there's some value to that so I'm
not sure if I can answer the question
the way you phrase it what I think
putting the two together to sort of the
science and really the big policy
questions in the US the biggest issue is
the Affordable Care Act and how that's
going to be implemented and how HIV is
covered within that how we bring
together the Ryan White Care Act
programs and structures and philosophy
to the Oklahoma care affordable care act
so I don't know did you have something
we were thinking that I'm not catching
in the question why don't you be policy
issues that stood out among I'm sure
what are the Mary is different policy
issues you have to do
but that are most significantly coming
up well I'll buy another one at once
again syringe exchange funding so you
New Yorkers know that we've been
fighting this battle forever and as soon
as there were it was even before the
data that communities figured out
injectors figured out that if you have a
sterile syringe or less likely to
acquire transmit HIV infection and
started setting up needle exchange
programs in the communities those
eventually got more institutionalized
and cities and localities we're helping
us support and fund and for all those
years they were in some cases still
illegal or kind of okay sanctioned but
not entirely legal for all those years
there were people like me advocating for
federal funding for syringe exchange
programs saying this is a very
efficacious HIV in fact this is a very
effective HIV prevention strategy we
have the data here to show over time
that where we've implemented where we've
seen needle and syringe exchange
programs implemented in the world HIV
infection rates among drug users have
dropped precipitously quickly too and it
was a political issue as you know still
is that a lot of people don't want to
spend taxpayer dollars on supplying
sterile syringes for people who inject
drugs so the whole harm reduction
approach is not one they were willing to
subscribe to well finally in two
thousand nine ten nine ten both Congress
and President Obama lifted the ban on
the use of federal funds for syringe
exchange we finally got legislative
language that allowed for US federal
dollars to be spent supporting syringe
exchange programs within a year it's
been I guess the only year Congress
undid it again so now we're back to
having a federal ban so that remains
till the day I die probably very
important and it is an implementation
science question in terms of the funding
support for making these programs stable
leading towards this question I'd love
to hear your reaction or some of your
experiences with um the signs of the
knowledge the ballot you know it's
considered valid knowledge itself is
sort of driven socially um so such as
which studies are funded or acoustics
out on an IRB so can you speak to your
experience of kind of people's
willingness to really actually undo sort
of our body of knowledge and understand
the best also socially driven zico has
my Italian friends would say honey
that's that's been a huge concern to me
I'm very much interested in the social
organization of science and there are
people in science and technology studies
who you know write and think maybe
yourself through the right and think a
lot about these kinds of questions but
the social organization of the
scientific enterprise including the
culture thereof and the way it's
structured is so entrenched I think
mainly from the NIH lens because that's
what is relevant in the US and it's
where I worked for a number of years and
saw it in spades and it's very very hard
to break and I mean we could talk again
hours on this and it has everything to
do with basic and biomedical and
clinical scientists and even
epidemiologists who are a little bit
closer to social science scientists who
think they know what social science is
because notwithstanding our own jargon
we speak in like normal words generally
speaking we don't have a lot of symbols
and you know the kind of biological
technological words that every time I go
to a basic science talk I think oh my
god you know this person is thrown out
gutless AB no vector and the gag and F
blah blah blah and I think that's not
jargon you know saying social
determinants of health is jargon so
there's that is just very widespread
that there's a sense that oh I
understand what you're saying therefore
I understand the science and I know what
social science is and it's kind of what
I've experienced in like thinking about
things am I you know my experiences in
the world and what my friends do and
stuff like that so they're very
uninterested in really grappling with
the rigor so that's one part the other
part is that as the talk was saying that
when
really dig in at a basic social science
11 look at fundamental social factors
causes determinants drivers of health
inequities it's too scary for people it
sounds like revolution it sounds like
you know me it is about major social
change and that just scares people and
they don't understand how you can study
that scientifically in this very
controlled sort of way and then the
third thing I'd say and this is a
particular beef of my own is that
there's a lot of conflation of
behavioral and social science and some
people actually live both pieces they
look at the individual and the
psychosocial and they're interested in
behavioral change but they're very aware
of and attended to the social context
but there's a lot of social science that
is really about how things operate at a
higher level of social organization not
reducing the individual behaviors and we
often social scientists and anthropology
sociology economics geography social
geographers for example often get
confused and completed with
psychologists and health psychologists
all due respect the psychologist in the
room who really have a different
orientation and can fit much better into
the clinical science methodology do
they're used to doing experimental
research with individuals and looking at
individual and often very specific
outcomes so that's I think a third
reason why it's been so intractable I'm
sure there are many others but there's
there is no interest in the biomedical
enterprise to unpack the social
organization of science
and at the risk of putting you on the
spot do you have anything optimistic for
cuts or something inspiring along
addressing that well I think the fact
that there is more recognition of things
like social determines and social
drivers and people like me do get asked
to sit at the table with folks and help
explain to them how this is science and
why it's important that's promising I
just get yet sort of one step forward
two steps back but I'm an optimist I
wouldn't still be in this for all this
time the opening is in we have someone
who's fighting for cause you change yeah
and funding so that's instance in
apartment we have you I was just I was
going to say when you're speaking to
social workers Vermont who appreciate
all the theoretical constructs of
sociology is what a psychology many of
us are behavioral behaviorist and
clinicians as well as I think on a more
macro level and I personally very
interested in implementation science and
don't want to lose sight of the larger
picture of sociology so in a way
sometimes we have to remind people
biomedical scientists that yes people
enjoy sex and that's part of the issue
here that we should think about what
would use what would you charge us with
then as we look at implementation
science so we don't lose sight of what's
important well I think it needs people
like you actually they don't make a
translation so a lot of our role also do
in squid question is it Owen Irwin l1
sorry and it has to do with positioning
oneself I don't know where you all are
in your career trajectory but I sort of
decided long ago that my role in life
was going to be to be the sort of token
and the you know the little advocate nip
in advance of that big bed biomedical
enterprise but no not really fit
translator the facilitator the person
and I'm not the only one but there
actually aren't that many of us but if
you can identify a place or you can get
positioned by people like me who or you
know have a lot of connections in this
world we're always looking for people
who can help make those translations in
a friendly and productive way and I
guess
this is a little bit back to Ellen's
question I really am a big believer in
bringing together the biomedical
behavioral and social and the more of us
who are sensitive to doing that and have
the skills to do that I am terrible i
have no biologic science background so i
can only go so far and then i get really
frustrated with my own in capacities but
there are a lot of people yourselves
properly included who have that range
you've just described that range pretty
well who can actually sit right now
where the field is going and help make
the translations across so you can pick
a topic I've recently worked in one on
sexual violence and HIV that started
with looking at the macro social
conflict situations in which rape and
sexual violence happens a lot but
getting down to the genital injury at a
very physiological level to realize you
have to look up and down that stream
through the behaviors you know the
what's happening is it rape is it inter
partner violence whatever is that using
condoms not using condoms you have to
look all the way up and down that to
understand the role of sexual violence
and HIV transmission and its impact for
let's say HIV infections among women so
people who can think across those
boundaries on a topic area like that or
something else that interests you I
think really have a place in the in the
field right now and will make a great
contribution so a lot of it is
positioning and just letting people know
that you're qualified in that way helps
a lot
they're very clear asleep yeah actually
do kind of like the same way
thinking about in terms of
you know this kind of knowledge be
distributed do you pin your opinion and
I know if this is under you come across
a new research do you find that because
to me it seems like this conversation
needs to be held in one in macro level
socially speaking and I think that in
order for people to stop depending on
this idea that drugs will take care of
the problem and stop looking at social
factor social cultural factors which
means very importance actually a big
influence in fact that considering that
you know HIV still affecting certain
populations and communities pretty bad
depending do you think that by having
this conversation more than macro level
that it will help that what do you mean
by having this conversation morning all
of me talking a dick talk it's also
social factors and how they influence
the spread of the disease itself the
reason I bring this up is because you
know what I mean that's highly effective
is minority wouldn't but yeah you know
women
Mary you know and there's the issue of
gay men who are secretly gay and you
know and that's not Demi demonize the
gay population it's to demonize the
social factors that create an
environment where they feel they can't
live opening so do you think that by
having that conversation I like and
being able to disseminate this
information do you find that that's a
conversation as taking place or is that
part of what's not what is not happening
a little of both so he's a little bit
back to the audience question or Ellen
all questions come back to yours I'm
afraid I can give this talk to a really
friendly audience like this one I can
wait for somebody to invite me to give
this talk to a less friendly audience
but that doesn't happen too much and I
always sort of joke about when you go to
the International AIDS conferences and
there's the really huge one that's
25,000 people that just happened in July
here that is scientists and community
advocates and policymakers and funders
and everybody huge mix there's another
one that happens every other year that
we were just talking about the bln I
that will be in Kuala Lumpur this next
summer that is considered the real
science conference because a lot of the
scientists got fed up with the huge
cacophony of the International AIDS
Conference and they said let's start one
that's really more science focused and
it started as treatment and clinical
science basic and clinical science that
expanded to prevention but only
biomedical prevention very explicitly
stated and now finally is a little bit
inclusive of behavioral and social
research well in those conferences you
know they're typically organized I'm
sorry this is a long story but there is
a point to it they're typically
organized by track so a is the track a
is the basic biological sciences track
B's the clinical sciences track see some
version of prevention or epidemiology
biomedical science track D is the social
science and now we have Trekkie the
implementation sites and what typically
happens is if there are plenty talk so
it talks to the whole audience in the
morning at the beginning these
conferences and you have a basic science
talk basic biomedical science talk on
vaccine and the place is packed and
social scientists like me are sitting in
their learning you know I'm
by osmosis all understand vectors and
all this stuff they're talking about and
then a social scientist if they're
invited which happened in Rome gets up
to give the talk half the room walks out
so it's really an audience issue I think
it's a little bit to my point earlier
that a lot of the biomedical and
clinical science community just doesn't
think it needs to hear it they're just
so interested in the science they do and
think that's all I need to hear we're
probably guilty of the same thing to
some extent and say well I understand or
don't understand this talk I'm not going
to it but I can't think we tend to sit
through more of that so there's still a
little bit of hold out and having the
right venues because i think the
scientific community is as much my
audience as any in fact it is my primary
audience policymakers certainly but it's
the biomedical in clinical science
community that I really dedicate my
stuff to the you want to say you need a
huge difference and if you will see how
your publication have been cited how
people use the language that you have
been using social science social
structure issues in HIV prevention you
move a huge difference one person with
one difference so when did you retire
well I think that was her plug also
pretty we were working on your degrees
to get there hello Judy you have been
very instrumental in making a big
difference about how people talk about
social science in HIV prevention well I
appreciate that it's been my mission and
I had not worked in academia for more
years than you're probably alive but I
made it a commitment to myself to keep
publishing however I could and partly
partly because I eventually had access
and thought you know people like me have
to use that to infiltrate so finish your
degrees get your publications and
infiltrate we're joining thankful